WE'RE COMING TO YOU WITH THE
SITUATION IN UKRAINE.
IT IS CHANGING BY THE MINUTE AND
THERE'S NO WAY TO OVERESTIMATE
THE GRAVITY OF IT.
VLADIMIR PUTIN HAS ORDERED
TROOPS INTO EASTERN UKRAINE.
ACCORDING TO A SENIOR GOVERNMENT
OFFICIAL FAMILIAR WITH THE
LATEST INTELLIGENCE, THE
EXPECTATION IS THEY COULD MOVE
IN AS SOON AS TONIGHT.
WHAT WOULD BE THE EARLY MORNING
HOURS.
WHAT'S MORE, IT IS UNDERSCORED
BY THE ENORMOUS NUMBER OF
RUSSIAN FORCES YOU SEE ON THE
MA'AM.
NEARLY A DOZEN OFFICIALS NOW
TELL CNN WHAT WE'VE SEEN SO FAR
TODAY APPEARS TO BE THE OPENING
SALVO OF A LARGER POSSIBLE
MILITARY ACTION.
JUST MOMENTS AGO, WE SAW VIDEO
BEING PLAYED ON THE RUSSIAN
OUTLET RTBI.
IT SHOWS TRUCKS WITH FIELD
ARTILLERY DOWN THE ROAD ON THE
CITY TO DONETSK.
WE DON'T KNOW WHO IT BELONGS TO.
IT FOLLOWED VLADIMIR PUTIN THIS
AFTERNOON SIGNING A DECREE
RECOGNIZING TWO PARTS OF EASTERN
UKRAINE AS INDEPENDENT REPUBLICS
AND SIGNIFICANTLY ORDERING
TROOPS INTO THE TERRITORIES.
AN INVASION OR OCCUPATION,
DESPITE THE PROPAGANDA THAT
PUTIN USES, CALLING IT
PEACEKEEPING.
EVEN MORE OMINOUS, WHAT HE HAD
TO SAY IN A LENGTHY AND
COMBATIVE SPEECH.
HIS REMARKS BEGAN WITH A TWISTED
HISTORY LESSON, DISTORTED TO
RUSSIA'S POINT OF VIEW.
HE ENDED WITH A THREAT TO ALL OF
UKRAINE.
IN FACT, A SORT OF DENIAL THAT
UKRAINE EVEN EXISTS.
>> Translator: I WOULD LIKE TO
REITERATE THAT UKRAINE IS NOT
OUR NEIGHBORING COUNTRY.
IT IS AN INTEGRAL PART OF OUR
OWN HISTORY, CULTURE, AND
SPIRITUAL SPACE.
UKRAINE FROM THE BEGINNING, AND
IN ITS TOTALITY HAS BEEN CREATED
BY RUSSIA.
THOSE WHO HAVE TAKEN THE POWER
AND ARE HOLDING THE POWER IN
UKRAINE.
WE DEMAND, STOP ANY OF THE
MILITARY ACTIONS.
OTHERWISE, THE RESPONSIBILITY
WILL BE ON THE GOVERNING --
GOVERNMENT IN UKRAINE.
>> QUITE A CONTRAST FROM REPORTS
EARLIER IN THE DAY OF
PREPARATIONS FOR A THURSDAY
MEETING BETWEEN RUSSIA'S FOREIGN
MINISTER AND SECRETARY OF STATE
BLINKEN IN PREPARATION FOR A
POSSIBLE BIDEN-PUTIN SUMMIT.
THE CONTRAST ALSO FROM THIS JUST
YESTERDAY FROM RUSSIA'S
AMBASSADOR TO WASHINGTON.
>> WE ARE NOT TRYING TO TAKE ANY
TERRITORY OF A FOREIGN COUNTRY.
I WOULD LIKE TO CONFIRM THAT
DONETSK AND LUHANSK IS A PART OF
UKRAINE.
>> SO MUCH FOR YESTERDAY.
TONIGHT AT THE WHITE HOUSE, IN
NATO CAPITALS ACROSS EUROPE, IT
IS TWOFOLD ON IMPOSING SANCTIONS
AND SADLY BRACING FOR THE IMPACT
OF WHAT COULD BE HOURS AWAY,
WHATEVER THAT MIGHT BE.
AS ONLY CNN CAN, WE HAVE REPORTS
FROM EVERYWHERE THAT MATTERS.
KAITLAN COLLINS AT THE WHITE
HOUSE, CNN CONTRIBUTOR JILL
DOHERTY IN MOSCOW, AND A
STRATEGIC CITY IN EASTERN KRUN.
I WANT TO START WITH CLARISSA
WARD WHERE PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY
HAS JUST MADE AN EARLY MORNING
ADDRESS TO THE COUNTRY.
WHAT DID HE SAY?
>> Reporter: THAT'S RIGHT, JOHN.
HE SPOKE AT ABOUT 2:00 IN THE
MORNING, JUST UNDER AN HOUR AGO.
AND ESSENTIALLY, HE ACCUSED
RUSSIA OF VIOLATING UKRAINE'S
TERRITORIAL INTEGRITY AND ITS
SOVEREIGNTY, THOUGH HE DID NOT
USE THE INVASION WORD.
HE ALSO SAID THAT HE DEMANDS,
QUOTE, CLEAR SUPPORT FROM THE
WEST IN TERMS OF THOSE
SANCTIONS.
THAT'S SOMETHING WE HAVE ALSO
SEEN ECHOED BY HIS FOREIGN
MINISTER WHO HAS TAKEN TO
TWITTER THIS EVENING, BASICALLY
SAYING THAT HE IS IN LOCK-STEP.
UKRAINE IS IN LOCK-STEP WITH ITS
ALLIES AND HE EXPECTS A RAFT OF
BLISTERING SANCTIONS TO BE
ANNOUNCED TOMORROW.
NOT CLEAR WHAT THOSE WOULD LOOK
LIKE YET.
ZELENSKYY ALSO THAT, WE DO NOT
FEAR ANYTHING AND WE WILL NOT
CEDE ANYTHING.
WHAT WE'RE SEEING ON THE GROUND
ALREADY, JOHN, ACCORDING TO
SOCIAL MEDIA POSTS, ACCORDING TO
REUTERS WHO ARE THERE, SOME FORM
OF MILITARY CONVOYS MOVING
THROUGH DONETSK.
AS YOU STATED, AND IT IS A
REALLY IMPORTANT CLARIFICATION
TO MAKE, WE CANNOT BE SURE IF
THIS CONVOY IS RUSSIAN MILITARY
OR PRO RUSSIAN SEPARATISTS.
WHAT WE DO KNOW IS THAT THIS
FRIENDSHIP AND SECURITY
AGREEMENT THAT PRESIDENT PUTIN
SIGNED EARLIER BETWEEN RUSSIA
AND THE REPUBLICS OF DONETSK AND
LUHANSK, AS THEY ARE NOW CALLING
THEMSELVES INDEPENDENT
REPUBLICS, THAT THIS BASICALLY
ALLOWS FOR PEACEKEEPING FORCES
TO BE DEPLOYED AS SOON AS NOW TO
HELP WITH SECURITY, TO HELP
DEFEND BORDERS, AND REALLY, THIS
RAISES TROUBLING CONCERNS ABOUT
HOW THE INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY
RESPONDS TO THIS.
DOES THIS CONSTITUTE AN
INVASION?
IS IT SIMPLY AN AREA THAT WAS
ALREADY UNDER DE FACTO MOSCOW
CONTROL?
AND SO I THINK FOR A LOT OF
PEOPLE IN UKRAINE TONIGHT, A LOT
OF ANXIETY, NOT JUST BECAUSE OF
RUSSIAN PEACE KEIMERS
POTENTIALLY ARRIVING AS WE SPEAK
IN THOSE BREAKAWAY REPUBLICS,
BUT ALSO, BECAUSE OF THE TONE OF
PRESIDENT PUTIN'S SPEECH WHICH
YOU JUST HIT ON.
ESSENTIALLY NEGATING THE VERY
EXISTENCE OF UKRAINE AS SOME
KIND OF A SOVEREIGN COUNTRY.
CALLING THE LEADERSHIP HERE A
PUPPET REGIME OF A COLONY.
AND RUNNING THROUGH A RAFT OF
HISTORICAL GRIEVANCES AGAINST
NATO WHICH REALLY APPEARED TO
MANY LISTENERS, I THINK FOR THE
FIRST TIME, TO POTENTIALLY PAVE
THE WAY FOR THE GROUNDWORK FOR
SOMETHING MUCH MORE EXPANSIVE
THAN WHAT WE'RE SEEING TONIGHT.
IT REMAINS TO BE SEEN WHETHER
THAT WILL GO AHEAD OR WHETHER
THIS IS JUST SOMETHING THAT
PRESIDENT PUTIN WILL NOW TRY TO
USE AS LEVERAGE IN FURTHER
DIPLOMATIC NEGOTIATIONS.
TO THE EXTENT THAT THOSE
DIPLOMATIC NEGOTIATIONS ARE
STILL ON THE TABLE, JOHN, WE
SIMPLY DON'T KNOW WHAT HAPPENS
NOW TOM MEETING BETWEEN BLINKEN
AND LAVROV, AND CERTAINLY, THE
FUTURE OF ANY SUMMIT BETWEEN
PUTIN AND BIDEN SEEMS FAR LESS
LIKELY IN THIS MOMENT.
>> KAITLAN COLLINS, TO YOU AT
THE WHITE HOUSE, WITH THE VERY
REAL POSSIBILITY THAT RUSSIAN
TROOPS MAY BE ALREADY IN PARTS
OF UKRAINE LIKE THIS, WHAT IS
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION'S
RESPONSE?
>> THEY SAY THEY'RE GOING TO
MONITOR THIS OVERNIGHT TO SEE
WHAT HAPPENS IN THESE HOURS.
IT IS ABOUT 3:00 A.M. IN
UKRAINE.
THEY ARE NOT READY TO CALL IT AN
INVASION YET.
THEY HAVE MADE THAT QUITE CLEAR
WITH REPORTERS AND ON CNN AS
WELL.
GIVEN WHAT THEY ARE SEEING ON
THE GROUND, THEY SAY THEY WANT
TO SEE WHAT PUTIN IS GOING TO DO
NOW THAT HE HAS SIGNED THIS.
THEY SAID IT WOULD BE DEFYING
INTERNATIONAL LAW.
THEY MADE IT QUITE CLEAR HOW
THEY VIEW WHAT PUTIN DID TODAY.
BUT THE WAY THEY ARE RESPONDING
IS STILL NOT CLEAR YET.
WE KNOW PRESIDENT BIDEN SIGNED
THIS EXECUTIVE ORDER EARLIER.
THAT PUTS THE LIMITED SANCTIONS
ON THESE AREAS, THESE BREAKAWAY
REGIONS OF UKRAINE.
IT NOT SANCTIONS ON RUSSIA YET.
NOT ON PUTIN YET.
THE ONE WE HAVE BEEN HEARING
OFFICIALS TALK ABOUT FOR WEEKS.
THOSE ARE NOT BEING UNLEASHED
YET.
IT APPEARS THEY'RE SAVING THAT
IN THE LIGHT OF A FULL-SCALE
INVASION.
THAT REMAINS TO BE SEEN HOW THE
WHITE HOUSE IS GOING TO RESPOND.
THEY HAVE TEASED SOME SANCTIONS
COMING TOMORROW, POTENTIALLY.
I THINK IT DEPENDS ON WHAT
HAPPENS OVERNIGHT BEFORE THEY
SEE WHAT THAT RESPONSE IS.
RIGHT NOW, THEY ARE NOT CALLING
THIS AN INVASION AT THE WHITE
HOUSE.
>> THAT IS INTERESTING.
ALEX, TO YOU IN EASTERN UKRAINE,
WHAT ARE YOU HEARING FROM
OFFICIALS ABOUT WHAT PUTIN'S
MOVES THERE COULD LOOK LIKE?
>> AS YOU SAID, EVERYONE
BELIEVES THIS IS THE OPENING
SALVO FOR WHATEVER PUTIN HAS
PLANNED.
WE JUST DON'T KNOW WHAT HE'S
THINKING FOR THE COMING HOURS
AND DAYS.
WE SPOKE WITH THE WESTERN
DIPLOMAT WHO SAID WE ARE IN A
NEW ERA AND A DANGEROUS ONE
BECAUSE OF THAT LACK OF
PREDICTABILITY.
NOW, WHAT IS ESPECIALLY
DANGEROUS ARE THESE SO-CALLED
PEACE KEIMERS IN THE DONBAS.
THIS IS AN AREA IN THE LAST FEW
DAYS WHERE RUSSIAN FORCES HAVE
ACCUSED UKRAINE OF CARRYING OUT
ATTACKS AGAINST THEM.
NOW THAT WE WILL LIKELY HAVE
OFFICIAL RUSSIAN TROOPS THERE,
WHAT HAPPENS IF THEY ENGAGE WITH
UKRAINE OR ACCUSE UKRAINE OF
ATTACKING THEM?
RUSSIA COULD THEN HAVE AN EXCUSE
TO FURTHER EXPAND THEIR
CAMPAIGN.
SO DO THEY WANT TO STAY IN THESE
TWO BREAKAWAY ENCLAVES FOR NOW?
THERE'S A WHOLE MENU OF OPTIONS
GIVEN THEIR POSITIONING ALL
AROUND UKRAINE.
THEY COULD TAKE THAT LAND BRIDGE
TO CONNECT CRIMEA WITH EASTERN
UKRAINE, WITH RUSSIA.
THEY COULD INVADE FROM THE
NORTH, WITH BELARUS, AND TRY TO
MOVE ON KYIV.
THEY COULD COME FROM THE SOUTH,
FROM CRIMEA, WHERE THEY HAVE
TROOPS, HELICOPTERS AND SHIPS,
AND THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS
REPEATEDLY SAID THEY COULD START
A REAL FULL-SCALE INVASION BY
BOMBING WITH MISSILES AND THEIR
FIGHTER JETS.
SO A LOT REMAIN TO BE SEEN IN
THE COMING HOURS AND DAYS.
I DID SPEAK WITH A EUROPEAN
DEFENSE OFFICIAL WHO TOLD ME, IF
HE GOES FOR WAR, HE HAS TO DO IT
FAST AND THEN START PREPARING
FOR PEACE NEGOTIATIONS.
>> SO PERILOUS HOURS TONIGHT, TO
BE SURE.
JILL, SO PUTIN HAS SIGNED THESE
DECREES REGARDING EASTERN
UKRAINE.
WHAT EXACTLY DO THEY SAY?
WHAT DO THEY AUTHORIZE?
>> Reporter: WELL, THEY
RECOGNIZE, NUMBER ONE, AND THAT
IS A VIOLATION OF THE
TERRITORIAL INTEGRITY AND THE
SOVEREIGNTY OF UKRAINE.
RECOGNIZES THESE TWO BREAKAWAY
REGIONS, DONETSK AND LUHANSK
PEOPLE'S REPUBLICS AND THEN THEY
HAVE A FRIENDSHIP COOPERATION
AND MUTUAL ASSISTANCE PART OF
THAT.
AND WITHIN THAT PART, THE
PRESIDENT, PRESIDENT PUTIN,
AUTHORIZES THE RUSSIAN MILITARY
TO CARRY OUT, TO ENSURE
PEACEKEEPING FUNCTIONS, IS THE
WAY IT IS PUT.
SO AGAIN, TACITLY -- THOSE
OFFICIALLY, ACCORDING TO THE
RUSSIANS, IN QUOTES THERE,
PEACEKEEPERS, BUT OBVIOUSLY THEY
CAN BE USED AS ANYTHING THEY
WANT.
BUT THAT'S KIND OF THE LEGAL
PART OF IT.
WHAT HE INTENDS TO DO WITH THAT,
OR THE FIG LEAF OF IT IS ANOTHER
QUESTION.
AND THE REAL FEAR, I THINK,
JOHN, IS THAT WE'VE BEEN SAYING,
THIS COULD OPEN THE DOOR TO ALL
SORTS OF THINGS THAT COULD
HAPPEN.
BUT IT REALLY DOES TEAR APART, I
THINK, ALSO, IT TEARS APART THE
MINSK ACCORDS WHICH WERE THE ONE
THING THAT PEOPLE WERE HOPING
EVENTUALLY COULD SOL